you gave you gave a really good just
bit there um a moment ago on how
the the the conscious
agent does not see the i think this this
is extremely important but like the rain
of photons that are coming right now
and this big um field of nitrogen and
oxygen
uh molecules in front of my face um
the electromagnetic spectrum that we
only see from 400 to 700 nanometers on
um the fact that we
don't see any of those things is
precisely because because
we potentially designed it this way so
that
we could act
in the ocean of that we're in
uh to have
experiences because if you couldn't have
those experiences
if you were blocked by the ocean
of the electromagnetic spectrum and the
sea
of oxygen and nitrogen that you're in
does that generally about right too
right from an evolutionary point of view
that would be the kind of argument that
um you
you want to evolve sensory systems that
tell you what you need to know to act
in ways that will keep you alive you
know that will keep you fit
but um you want to do it as cheaply as
possible right
every calorie that you spend on
perception
is a calorie that you have to go out
kill something
and eat it to get that calorie so there
are selection pressures for uh to
to dumb things down to keep our senses
as simple as possible
given the the other pressure of they
have to be complicated enough to
accurately report fitness at least
more accurately and and more fitness
than than your competition there's
there's nothing that
in evolutionary theory that says that
you are perfect about seeing fitness
either right so i'm not
i'm not being um a theorist that says
we're we have vertical perceptions of
even fitness payoffs there's nothing
vertical here anywhere
we we have what we call satisficing
solutions and evolution
right is good enough to just beat the
competition and so
so and from that point of view from an
evolutionary point of view and again
you can see my attitude is look i'm not
saying that evolution by natural
selection is true but i'm saying we have
no better theory but that that is the
best theory we've got so
so until we have a better theory we've
got to take it very very seriously
in what it says and then try to break it
right i mean
the icon so we have to respect it really
study
it and then also try to break it so so
what that theory is saying
is yeah there's no selection pressures
for you to know everything
quite to the contrary all you need to do
is be a little bit better than the
competition
and so why should we see the the deep
structure of
atomic nuclei or the the wavelength
structure of photons and so forth
and and the fact that we in science
uh you know run into these things
is interesting what we're doing
is we're studying our headset right
our headset has evolved with certain
structure to it
like we have us a space time that we
perceive intuitively you know three
dimensions
of space and one dimension of time but
when we actually
study our perceptions more
systematically
we realize it was you know einstein
comes along and and
comes up with surprising features about
our interface that eventually lead to
posing that there's a minkowski
structure to space-time
and then eventually even a curved space
time he comes up with a curved space
time
and then when we so what's happening is
we're taking the language of our senses
the language of our interface that was
evolved
and what science has do has been doing
is studying our interface we haven't
been studying
objective reality we've been studying
our interface and its structure
and even microphysical particles like
quarks and gluons and leptons
are the physicists will tell you they're
just what they call irreducible
representations of the poincare group
but that means that they're
they're representing symmetries of
space-time we have this
space-time format for our headset and
particles are just representations of
the symmetries of that
of that formatting system and so
so yeah we haven't seen all this stuff
and um until science came along
and it and what science has been doing
is systematically exploring our headset
um and and and it's taken a lot of hard
work right you
thousands of brilliant scientists
working really really hard
which gets back at your main point which
in some sense from evolution
we weren't evolved to see this otherwise
it wouldn't be that hard we would just
see it
so so why it just takes like it takes an
einstein
it takes you know we the people who
actually figure this stuff out we
we view them as absolute geniuses right
that means that
because in some sense the rest of us
mortals
would never have even thought of that
and so there are a few of us
like the einsteins and the john wheelers
and
and and so forth who have these really
deep insights
um and then the rest of us um you know
feel smart
by association yeah it
absolutely a power law of brilliant
people that have pushed the edge of what
is known 1 billion people have been
uncommon and 99 billion people have been
common and um yeah yeah and the ones
that are
uncommon are the ones that make the
mutations
on that uh universal constructor um
that we're a part of and then that tape
uh then a hundred years later we're all
flying airplanes you know
uh style um
yeah the um the the other
the other thought for me around um
the perception as you were indicating a
moment ago
which i think is really valuable is that
when
when when one augments their user
interface when one augments their
perception
um in a sense what they do is they they
kind of like
climb the ladder of abstraction um
but what happens is they like they see
the world in a higher resolution like
when when we're talking about the
electromagnetic spectrum and the sea of
of oxygen nitrogen etc that that is
that's here the photons etc
all all that all that would we've done
is we've conceptualized these things
then we've
stored it but then we don't continue
seeing it all the time
so yeah so so this is a key insight i
think is
you rise to the levels of abstraction of
knowing this
and then you store it as a concept so
like you double click in
you see the higher resolution and then
what you do is you zoom back
out and you've stored that data and then
you go about your
the rest of your um the whatever the
function is and like
you described earlier there's many ways
up this mountain so
we're not just saying that it is only um
procreation
but that is definitely high and uh truth
is also
high the more that you know about truth
the greater chance you have of getting a
mate as well
um but people that are tuned
specifically towards
um fitness payoffs like you indicated um
versus just truth payoffs
um fitness payoffs will win out um over
that but there is there is an
an overlap there but i i appreciate that
that understanding of of upgrading
perception and then
and then holding that as abstract
concepts that you can access any time
versus not even having yeah that
that's a good point in the sense that um
even the best
of scientists when they reach some deep
new understanding like
quantum theory and you find that that
these
electrons and photons are in
superposition states and they get
entangled and so forth
um the best and brightest you know like
richard feynman will say look um
if you think you understand this you
don't understand this no no one
understands this this is just
this is mind-boggling stuff and and so
these geniuses who
who are at the forefront of under
working on it will will say that it it
just
shatters all of your your intuitions and
from an evolutionary point of view you
could say well
no surprise i mean we weren't in some
sense evolved to understand
the subatomic world and and so our our
concepts
and intuitions just aren't matched to it
and when we get there
we get there by mathematics right the
the
we're forced to these conclusions
because we
we try to get some mathematics that will
explain our experiments
when we get the mathematics and finding
oh wow finally an equation
that matches the data so what does this
equation entail
it entails that are you you got to be
kidding me it means that there's
superpositions
that there is entanglement i don't even
know this is
it and so then you have the really
brilliant people going i have no idea
what what this really means all i know
is that that's what the math
is saying and my intuitions are are
boggled and so
so that's that's where we are
on that and
there in terms of
perceiving the truth and and getting
mates
um yeah mentioned um
from an evolutionary point of view there
is an interesting
for for our species um
there's an interesting sexual selection
pressure
so a male
that has special linguistic
or cognitive abilities can
by showing off perhaps be more
attractive
to females that's just one way that you
can show off you could also show off by
being physically strong
right and fast or muscle there's never
ways of showing off but
but there are some selection pressures
for for women to
be more attracted to
to males with um better displays of
cognitive abilities
and and that can lead not necessarily to
truth
but to just making up really impressive
stories
and and just trying to look impressive
so
so the alphabet soup logical fallacy
right so so they're they're you know
just
performing in a way that makes you look
impressive
may or may not be necessarily moving
toward the truth now in the case of an
einstein right um
but if you've stored this data like if
you've stored the quantum field around
the tree with the
exchange that is happening of
photosynthesis between the human and the
tree in terms of o2 and co2 if you've
stored that data if you've stored also
how you eat the apple that's went
through the
photosynthetic process of making the
glucose and then you eat that and you go
through the cellular respiration process
if you've stored these pieces of data um
and you know them and you can recall
them
they give you a scientific and a
spiritual
fitness advantage in that sense over
other potential mates for
whoever that that doesn't know that data
absolutely in the following sense i mean
knowing that kind of stuff i i know
um things that could change my behavior
so that i would eat more healthily
and and and be more healthy that way or
i could
devise new technologies that allows me
and my tribe to beat the others
and and therefore be more fit in that so
absolutely that's one thing that's
driven
science is the need for technologies to
fight
other human beings um so a lot of
i mean so and it works right it's you
know
the united states is the world
superpower not because um
we're the smartest people or the
strongest people or the bravest people
we just happen to have the best
technology that that's that's that's it
that's so it's really in that sense the
fitness
in an evolutionary sense goes now with
great
technology in the past it was um you
know who knew how to throw
sticks and and rocks better and then
figure out levers and then bows and
arrows right
that was a you know bow and arrow
unbelievable technology
it gives you an incredible advance until
the other tribe figures out oh
look what they did and they so now you
get this arms race and so that
is so you're right that there is in some
sense this this
fitness payoff for better and better
technologies absolutely
and and that um is one of the selection
pressures
uh sexual selection pressures women will
be impressed not just with brawn
but also with brain in our species
yeah so so interesting
on that point um let's um
let's talk about um and everything that
we just mentioned would it be fair to
say that those are
upgrades in perception in your
multimodal
user interface that these are upgrades
that we can make like if your dashboard
sees like from the old school days of
how to make the bow and arrow
or from today's modern day maybe you
know how to use python to program a
computer
that may be that if you have those
little icons
on your multimodal user interface that
maybe then
in this interface theory of perception
if i can perform some mimesis and i can
learn how to do the bow and arrow or i
can learn how to do the python
programming and add that to my
multimodal user interface perception
that then then that is
the upgrades in perception augmentations
and perception that enable me to climb
those ladders of fitness and abstraction
and truth and stuff like that
that that's right it's it's an upgrade
not in the sense of the basic hardware
of the brain right the
the hardware of the brain that you got
is what you've got
but you can because our our
our brains are have evolved to be
learning algorithms and when we we learn
and build models
and if a lot of other people
around us that we see have figured out
models that we might not have figured
out on ourselves
we can effectively be more smart because
we can instead of figuring ourselves we
can just
adopt their model now we have their
model even if we weren't smart enough to
actually figure it out
ourselves and so as our population has
gotten bigger
seven billion or eight billion and so
forth yeah you know right there's
there's a
we have that many people out there
there's going to be some some real
geniuses
who will come up with big ideas like
there'll be ann einstein
and we we all talk about einstein
and there are a billion other people
that we're not going to talk about from
from 1905
um that that and but the the zero to one
and then the one to many as peter two
would say
yeah that's right but there is a i'll
tell the opposite side of this now and
that's it's quite remarkable
um our brains in some sense are not
upgrading
they're downsizing that's right yeah
what is it is it the volume of a tennis
ball
we've lost in the last 20 000 years
that's exactly right
um so the peak
was 15 20 000 years ago and apparently
then
what seems to be going on um well
what what is going on in the data is
that they can measure the
the volume of the of the skulls the
cranium so that you can measure you know
the brains are gone but you can see
the volume that they occupied and so you
can actually measure we've lost in the
last
15 20 000 years um 10
15 of our our brain volume of the
the about the entire volume of a tennis
ball is gone
so it's it's truly stunning and and
apparently we got smart enough 15 000
years ago
to create a agriculture
and with agriculture we started to get
now with to support agriculture you need
to bring
um a bigger social group we have small
social groups as hunter-gatherers but
now you need to
bring together bigger social groups and
you have to have a bigger division of
labor because
you know we had to be you know tending
the crops
um working with the crops um we could
then we needed people to defend the
crops because the hunter-gatherers are
going to come through and just try to
steal it from you right so you got to
now you have to have a standing army
they can't be always doing the crops and
so
you get this division of labor that's
that's coming out but once you get a
division labor
um i don't have to be smart about
everything now if i'm a hunter gatherer
me and my small group
we have to do everything or we die right
we have to make our clothes
we have to take care of ourselves when
we're sick everything that we need we've
got to do ourselves or steal from
somebody
and but you know greater selection
pressure for being a polymath 20 000
years ago and then the slowly
we've relieved those selection pressures
today
where you're just exchanging the sheet
of paper for the apple
instead of growing it yourself yeah yeah
an iq of 70 and just go to the store and
get my food
as you know i mean iq 70 probably you
know
during the 15 000 years ago i would have
been run over
so it's you know it's so it's a use it
or lose it
kind of situation or use it you only get
it if you need it
and since um i don't need to do
everything i don't need to be
a genius at everything as much as before
i'm not and so our brains
are being downsized
i i as as also we're at least
you know we have this access to the
internet and we're moving into the
genetic engineering the neural
prosthetic ages
that we're getting potentially the
assistance of these
agi coaches and we can maybe learn how
to augment our working memory
to 20 plus or minus two and maybe we can
abstractly reason
such novel concepts that have never been
thought of before
and um but so maybe there is a way to
kind of bounce
back from that loss uh maybe um
that would be that would be good um and
yeah yeah um let's let's this is good
that that was a good bit on
those um augmentations i definitely
think that um
there's many other um augmentations that
that exist like entheogens is a is a
prominent
um augmentation that exists um deep
the depth of meditative experiences the
deepest steps of those as well
um augment one's perceptions also enable
them to
really um understand what the pause is
instead of being so reactive they can uh
they know how to slow down and just
observe and then
um which is game changing for your
relationships with your family your
friends your co-workers
people online blah blah and so all of a
sudden
just from something that doesn't appear
to have
a high fitness payoff right it doesn't
appear to have a high fitness payoff but
really when you learn how to pause
instead of immediately react
it gives you tremendous fitness payoff
downstream i i i would agree
in in the sense that especially like in
our society right now
right um most of us
aren't facing on a daily basis um
immediate threats to our our bodies but
it's you know there of course i mean
there are many murders in the united
states and around the world but
but it's you know as as pinker has
pointed out
stephen pinker in some of his books the
rate of of
homicide is dropped dramatically over
the centuries dramatically
and and so we have the luxury now
of not having to
look over our shoulders every moment you
know
worrying whether some other human being
from another tribe
is going to be attacking us or so forth
and so
so it's it's it's interesting that
if you're in a situation where you're in
a war zone
and um there are imminent threats all
the time
then being anxious and being alert
is very very fit right it's very very
important
eventually that anxiety and the cortisol
that it produces will kill you
but it won't kill you today and it will
keep you alive today so
in that sense it's more but now we have
this luxury
we're not an imminent threat they're not
imminent danger
so if we're in the state of of high
stress and anxiety
and so forth producing cortisol all the
time we are unnecessarily shortening our
lives
if i was in a war zone i would be
necessarily shorting shortening my life
but to stay alive today
so so with meditation and so forth
we can move into a greater sense
of peace and reduced stress and anxiety
we can reduce our cortisol levels
um and we can enjoy that that state of
life
now it's because of our you know from an
evolutionary point of view
um we are programmed
with a stress system right we have an
amygdala we have all
they're there um because that's what
kept us alive
we are the offspring of those who are
anxious enough
to be able to face the threats
successfully right so
that's why we have this proclivity to be
anxious
um there are variations among us but as
i mean
there's this video i saw in some
national geographic
show about nature or something with a
bunch of monkeys in the wild
but they're all the monkeys are up in
the trees and and gluten hollering and
so forth
except for one this one monkey was this
uh
really relaxed laid back monkey out in
the grass
oh you know and while they're filming
they haven't
some tiger or panther comes along and
guess who he got
yeah yeah that that relaxation gene just
went out of the gene pool
it was the only it was only the monkeys
that were uptight and
scared enough to stay in the trees
that's that that passed on their genes
and so
so we we are the offspring of those who
were are you know anxious enough
so so from an evolutionary point of view
um there's a clean
reason why most of us
face stress and anxiety even when we
don't have to what we feel it when we
don't have to
so evolution you know programmed us that
way but but meditation
is something that we can now do when we
have the luxury of not being in a war
zone not being attacked all the time
then we can
you know take the bull by the horn and
say look um
i don't need to be anxious all the time
even though i've been programmed
by natural selection to be anxious i i
can choose
to meditate and literally reprogram my
brain circuits
to be more relaxed uh and i will
enjoy my life more and statistically i
will live longer
yeah there's there's many of
variables in our user interface that
sometimes seem to uh
not have a high fitness payoff but
they're um because most of the high
fitness payoffs just
appear to be the short-term
gratifications
um and also the um
things involving money but the things
that are sometimes involving learning
how to do things that are maybe
thousands of years old like learning how
to investigate your own
consciousness and awareness and calm
down and become more peaceful and
joyful that uh doing that
doesn't seem to immediately have a
monetary or fitness payoff but it
but i think there are many things like
that that exists
that um get you closer to truth get you
closer to peace and joy
um that actually do give you better
downstream fitness payoffs
because that's the thing is that mates
given procreation
um men and women both that don't
have as keen of an interest
for truth um there
they in a sense it feels like there's
less soul
there there's more soul with people that
have a depth of interest and truth and
also we as a society need to do a better
job at creating the economic
incentives that make it so that young
children
can explore metaphysics and
consciousness
as a profession and get paid for it too
so if there's
you know money intertwined with truth
more carefully
then maybe some of those conscious
agents could win um
over people that just focus on fitness
um and
and money so yeah absolutely and and
um again as i said before you know i as
a scientist i'm always
just sort of saying what different
theories entail right
so i've been very very careful to say
that this is what evolutionary theory
entails and so forth
but but that i don't necessarily believe
the theory but now what you're saying is
very interesting suppose
uh you know no not forget evolutionary
theory suppose that
there's a deeper theory in which
consciousness is fundamental
and in some sense maybe this dynamics of
consciousness is really
what it's about is the exploration of
consciousness that's what's really
deep meaningful in this deeper realm of
consciousness right
and and so perfectly right
then puts a very different spin on the
whole meditation thing than the spin i
just gave right the spin i just gave was
from an evolutionary point of view which
says
uh it's just a way of countering the the
built-in anxieties that we have and
so that would that was that was you know
bracketed within that theory so now i'll
put that theory aside and say okay
that's what that theory entails
but there's this other framework
entirely different in which
consciousness is fundamental and it's
what it's all about
so in that case then meditation might
not be just this side little issue to
make us more
comfortable be that
that's only that's when we really wake
up to what we're really about that
maybe we're immersed in a game but the
point of the game isn't to win the game
maybe the point of the game is to wake
up yep
realize who we are and maybe playing the
game is a way
of more more deeply understanding um who
we are as conscious beings and and so
maybe
most of us just don't wake up in this
game so but again notice
i'm not saying that i know that this is
true and and that's the key thing
dogmatism from my point of view is the
is the
the worst thing we we could ever have
yeah assuming that i know the truth
is the way you stop inquiry so so i
always want to say
this is now i'm bracketing it with this
theory in a theory in which
consciousness is fundamental
then it would it would have this
different spin on things
and so that's what we we should always
even if that's right you can never know
that you're right that's the weird thing
about this so this is the human
condition
we can never know for right we can find
out many cases
that were deeply wrong but but we can
never so
there's this deep humility that we need
to have anything
we claim um it's rather
the way i like to think about i propose
the theoretical framework in which i'm
going to speak
and then say within that framework this
is what it entails but of course the
theory could be wrong
so here's here's what evolution entails
here's what the theory which
consciousness is fundamental
entails um but but maybe both theories
are deeply deeply wrong and so then
let's talk about a different framework
right and and so that's how we we yes
yes
the theories as opposed to being
attached to them yes
it's an anti-dogmatic kind of point of
view it's more
um exploring and and
if we assume that we know then we cut
off inquiry
and we can't learn if you know if you're
certain that you know
then you're not going to be motivated to
learn
yeah this is paramount um balancing
excitement with uh non-dogmatism because
you have to have confidence in
what edge you're trying to push and you
have to have humility
as well uh exactly exactly
that's that's the knife edge i agree
with you see
it's not easy for us to to maintain that
but it's really critical
it's so so critical um but because
especially
sometimes young people are are trying to
push with confidence something that may
be
actually really critical to get to the
edge and beyond the edge
but then there are influences of maybe
parents or community or friends
that are just hating on them um
moving that forward and so that there's
also the importance of of that of that
confidence and courage to to get
to to that edge and to to push it and
rocket it forward
it's very important oh absolutely i
think that that you've touched on a
really important point i mean
so the the theory that i'm working on
right now i i'm excited about it
i've got energy you know i think i'm on
to something
but and so you and you need to have that
kind of energy and that kind of
enthusiasm to push forward right
but then i always step back and go but
of course i could be wrong i mean i hope
i'm not but you
but you know you have to have that that
that dual understanding about the whole
situation
so yeah be motivated be excited but but
not dogmatic that's the knife edge
yep yep those are some of the codes that
we are archiving
from the dirty bath water is the
dogmatism and the fundamentalism and
we're taking the baby out um
the scientific method we're taking out
the
hierophanies these sacred divine
communions and experiences subjective
ones that people do have
and sharing those better